[Música]
alguna vez se han preguntado si regresan
a salvar sus casas después de una noche
de fiesta
bueno pues yo no tuve esa suerte la
noche del 19 de abril del 2015
aquel sábado hice ejercicio y de ahí me
fui a valle de bravo
todo estaba bien
se prepara para preparar para la fiesta
me cambié mi perfume me puse guapo para
pasarla increíble como siempre ya saben
23 años reventado salida los fines de
semana y como no una o varias copas y
como dice el dicho más vale pedir perdón
que pedir permiso
llegó la noche y un amigo y yo nos
fuimos de antro todo estaba bien está
pasando increíble mientras bailaba y
contaba con una amiga
de repente una chava choca conmigo y
cuando me volteé para disculparme y
corroborar que estaba bien de la nada
recibió un botellazo en la cabeza desde
la espalda y caí al piso con el cráneo
roto
aquel golpe me provocó un traumatismo
cráneo-encefálico cerebro hemisférico
izquierdo y daño acción al difuso qué es
eso
eso significa que mi cerebro se dañó
tanto que se perdieron las conexiones
entre el cerebro y el cuerpo o algo así
saben el perdón libera pero ustedes
perdonarán la persona que les quitó la
vida
en el hospital después de los estudios
los médicos pensaron que era un caso
perdido
los pronósticos indicaban que lo más
probable era que yo evolucionará en un
coma permanente y que por lo tanto que
nunca volvería a estar bien
en definitiva fue una noticia fuerte
para mi familia y amigos
día a día fuimos vencidos los
pronósticos poco a poco fui mejorando
por ejemplo
antes de eso estuve tres semanas
aproximadamente
y después de eso muy contrario de lo
pronosticado los doctores entré a un
estado de mínima conciencia
10 l
fuerte vamos más
los tres avales 4
y poco a poco fui mejorando día a día
vencimos los pronósticos por ejemplo el
día que me quitaron la traqueotomía ese
día aunque estaba en riesgo inminente de
perder el habla y las probabilidades
científicas eran casi nulas logré hablar
y mis primeras palabras fueron te amo
mamá
más fuerte y más verde
córdoba
después de tres duros meses del hospital
soportando terapias y trabajando mucho
me dieron de alta y regresé a casa
y ahí empezó mi verdadera lucha
el doctor les habilitó a mis padres que
era probable que perdiera parte de mi
memoria en especial aquellas
experiencias traumáticas que había
vivido en el hospital y ese pronóstico
si se cumplió
era mi primer día en casa amaneciendo
intenté levantarme de la cama para ir al
baño y sorpresa no puede levantarme sin
saber por qué no recordaba nada del
accidente ni el hospital por efectos del
traumatismo craneoencefálico
ese día me enteré de que no puede
caminar que hablaba muy mal que
necesitaba usar silla de ruedas que
perdí la vista con el ojo izquierdo y
también que estuve tres meses en el
hospital a punto de morir
no podía creerlo la noticia fue tan
fuerte para mí que yo creía que era un
simple sueño una pesadilla en el yo no
podía caminar y estar solo ni un minuto
y eso me impactó tanto que me costaba
trabajo aceptar que eso era ahora mi
realidad
y después de algún tiempo me di cuenta
conscientemente de que no estaba soñando
así que llegó la aceptación
acepte que realmente estaba en esa
tremenda situación
no puede caminar y hablaba como robot ya
había olvidado mucho vocabulario así que
tenía que aprender a caminar y hablar
era como si un bebé vivía dentro del
cuerpo de un joven de 23 años
según mis estudios cognitivos tenían la
mentalidad de un niño de 10 años
los médicos creían que en el mejor de
los casos llegaría a recuperar un 40 por
ciento de mis capacidades intelectuales
y físicas no más
así que caí en depresión no tenía ganas
de vivir tenía muchos pensamientos sobre
cómo quitarme la vida
creí que había conspirado en mi contra
no entendía nada
no lo estabas ganas a mis terapias que
me aburrían y no le encontraba sentido a
esforzarme
[Música]
creí que ya había caducado mi increíble
vida pensé que ya era hora de partir e
incluso sentía que era un peso muy
grande para mi familia y amigos y no
quería molestarlos y quitarles tiempo en
cuidarme así que mi mente comenzó a
generar ideas sobre cómo morir por
ejemplo pensé en aventar me de mi
departamento que está que está en el
piso 18 o meterme una tina y no respirar
bajo el agua y lo peor del caso es que
vivía odiando a un desconocido
odiaba al hombre que me dejó en ese
estado sentía mucho rencor y mis
pensamientos se concentraban mucho en él
en la injusticia de este sábado
quería vengarme me imaginaba haciéndole
el mismo daño que él me hizo a mí porque
creía que sobre la justicia
me preguntaba constantemente porque él
podría estar haciendo lo que quiera sin
límites físicos mientras yo tenía que
estar encerrado en mi cuarto acostado en
mi cama sin poder levantarme y cuando
llegaba a salir de casa era solo para ir
a terapias que me provocaban fuertes
dolores también pensaba en mi gusto que
era que él pudiera irse de fiesta y
tener una vida normal mientras yo estaba
luchando por recuperar lo que antes
tenía
mi vida se reducía a sentir
desesperación y depresión
vivía proyectado en esa oscura realidad
estaba en el papel de víctima al máximo
potencial y en ese papel no existía la
sonrisa ni la esperanza ni la motivación
y la energía ni nada
y me chocaba cuando la gente mi
alrededor me pedía que lo perdonara
claro como yo es nuestra en mi situación
se sentía lo que yo sentí en ese momento
si hubiera dado cuenta de que para mí
era imposible perdonarlo
no sé por qué me insistían tanto con
perdonarlo desde afuera parece fácil
pero para mí era imposible perdonar al
que después de un tiempo me enteré que
se llamaba miguel aquel hombre que me
cambió la vida
mi familia todos los días me decía lo
mismo que lo perdona no sé por qué me
insistían tanto es más cuando me lo
mencionaban diego hacia que incluso lo
odiara más estaba harto de que lo
mencionara
y recuerdo que algunos días después
había una noche en la que me encontraba
en mi cama reflexionando y lleno de
coraje gritando pegándole a la almohada
llorando y de repente mi mamá entre
habitación y sin esperarlo ella me hizo
una pregunta
hoy es julio estás enamorado del chavo
que te pego
aquí
cuando me hice esa pregunta me dieron
muchos sentimientos como se le pudo
haber ocurrido eso llama
estaba muy confundido e incluso ofendido
dije mamá qué te pasa estás loca o que
estás drogada
mamá qué te pasa acá
y minado me respondió
y si la cuestión es más cómo voy a estar
enamorado de ese hombre mamá como
y mi mamá me respondió
perdón julio perdón yo creí eso porque
todo el tiempo piensas en él siempre
quiere saber dónde está que hace que no
hace dónde vive si salió de fiesta o no
y pues dijo eso es lo que hace la gente
enamorada no perdón me confundí y
entonces salió de mi habitación
cuando se fue yo estaba muy confundido y
lleno de coraje como se le pudo haber
ocurrido eso a mi mamá
ustedes creen que yo estaba enamorado de
ese hombre
para mí eso fue un golpe bajo
después de calmar el enojo que le tengo
mi madre me di cuenta esa pregunta me
hizo darme cuenta de que él estaba
otorgando mucho poder sobre mí a mi guel
un simple desconocido
no mejoraba porque mis pensamientos
estaban concentrados en el mimma tenía
razón parecía que estaba enamorado de
ese hombre
ya me cayó el veinte y entendí que la
pregunta de mi mamá era válida pero
seguía sacado de onda porque la hizo
después ha reflexionado algunas horas la
pregunta mi madre
pensé en la insistencia que me habían
hecho todos acerca de perdonarlo
entonces puede calmar el enojo que le
tiene mi madre me pregunte julio
que puedes perder si lo perdonas
y mi ego gritaba nos julio no los
perdones
decidí no escuchar a mi ego y la
respuesta que encontré fue julio no
pierdes nada
el perdón es una palabra sencilla pero
no es fácil expresarla ni sentirla
esa noche lo saqué de mi cabeza mediante
el perdón y crearme el perdón es el
mejor regalo que me ha dado en esta vida
después de fusionar la pregunta mi madre
y decidir perdonarlo comencé a rezar y
pedir por el bien del agresor pedir por
el bien de miguel
así parecía incluso más que estaba
enamorado de él
al día siguiente mi vida era totalmente
diferente estaba muy concentrado en mí
están hechas novenas a mí terapias sin
mire que en mi cabeza veía posible
volver a caminar así que me encontraba
motivado por trabajar mucho en mí pero
no fue tan sencillo y de repente miguel
aparecía en mi cabeza a veces en la
mitad de mi terapia me lo imaginaba
burlándose de mí por no poder caminar o
no lo imaginaba corriendo y bailando
entonces regresaba mi coraje
llega a ser un ejercicio para fortalecer
el perdón
cada vez que miguel venía mis
pensamientos hacia una pausa sin
importar lo que estoy haciendo respira
profundo
le mandaba a ese hombre la mejor vibra
entonces lo sacaba de mi mente fuera de
mi muy lejos
no es tan sencillo el perdón es una
decisión pero se cree trabajo constante
para realmente limpiar la mente y sanar
el alma con el perdón
de hecho incluso después de haberlo
perdonado y saber lo saca de mi mente
había ocasiones en las que editaba de
coraje por mi situación y quería volver
a tener un culpable
creo volver a culpar a miguel el coraje
y de sentimientos que tienen que
trabajar mucho necesita tiempo y trabajo
constante para realmente limpiar la
mente y sanar el alma con el perdón
hoy en día ese hombre no llega en ningún
momento mis pensamientos y cuando lo
traigo yo conscientemente luego traigo
para bendecirlo y posteriormente sacarlo
de mi mente cuando lo traigo ahora no es
para odiarlo sino para agradecerle ya
que este evento me cambió la vida
me di cuenta de lo afortunado que
siempre he sido por tener a la familia
ya los padres que tengo ya que nunca los
valores ni los ame de esta manera
gracias miguel por ponerme esta enorme
prueba
poco tiempo después de haberlo perdonado
logré dar mis primeros pasos al dar mis
primeros pasos tuve un sentimiento
indescriptible de emoción felicidad
positivismo era algo enorme alarmismo
unos pasos en mi mente con como que me
pusieron a las mi mente comenzó a ver
nuevas rutas nuevos caminos con destinos
que me llevaban a mi recuperación al
100%
y bueno
fue un poquito de onda como pudieron
notar
a grandes cambios un golpe en la cabeza
ya que tengo en pretexto
y bueno después de los pasos y de
sentimental motivado
pues empecé a cambiar mi vida a positiva
empecé a darme cuenta en lugar de
quejarme y ver todo lo que no funciona
mi vida comencé a ver aquello que si
funciona lo que sí tengo del accidente
no lo que perdí sino que gane
y aparte de re aprender a caminar y
hablar
aprendí a amarme a mí mismo y aprendí a
no dar nada por hecho como el amor y la
vida
también aprendí a que no podemos dejar
que la vida se nos pase tenemos que
pasar nosotros por la vida pisando
fuerte dejando huella
esto lo conseguí aprendiendo a perdonar
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]